antoine bonjour la russie a donc refusé
de ratifier les coupes supplémentaires
dans la production proposée par l'opep
pour endiguer la baisse des prix sur
fond de demande mondiale en repli avec
la propagation du court aux navires us
quelles sont les conséquences pour
l'économie russe un exemple tout simple
après un week-end de trois jours la
bourse de moscou a rouvert ce matin en
forte baisse un peu plus de 10% de
baisse dans le sillage des autres places
financières mondiales la monnaie russe
souffre également l'euro s'échange
actuellement un peu au dessus des 80
roubles et a même franchi la barre des
85 roubles durant la journée d'hier un
niveau qu'il n'avait plus atteint depuis
un peu plus de quatre ans maintenant
pour autant le ministre russe de
l'énergie a souligné que le secteur
pétrolier russe ne risque rien à l'heure
actuelle et resterait même compétitif
dans des conditions de prix bas du
pétrole écouter l'industrie pétrolière
russe dispose d'une base de ressources
de qualité et d'une marge financière
suffisante pour rester compétitives
quels que soient le niveau de prix ainsi
que pour maintenir sa part de marché
même si la russie paraît disposer de
réserves suffisantes pour encaisser un
choc pétrolier ne il ne faudrait pas que
la situation dure trop longtemps car
cela se serait alors les politiques
sociales promises par le gouvernement
est attendu par la population qui en
souffriraient alors antoine claireaux en
direct depuis moscou merci pour toutes
ces précisions